[Music]
Hello, how are you? Natale Lancelot greets you
and with your brief informative for today,
Friday, August 6, the burial of the
people of en age
mika makes will take place today. He died
after being beaten by a
car theft suspect after a chase over
the interstate 15 may he was 46 years old
who leaves behind a wife and two children the
procession will begin at
half past nine in the morning in
downtown and will end at the
henderson central christian church where
a man hit
by a police car will be his funeral  of north las vegas
passed away Wednesday night
police said an officer was responding to
a call in the area when he
struck a person who was walking out of the
assigned crosswalk near
boulevard and lake mead metropolitan police are
continuing the
investigation and if  you have not yet received
the vaccine against cover and you do not know
where to get it we tell you that today
there will be a first dose clinic
inside silverstone
this  The location is also
offering appointments for the 12th and 27th of
this month from 8 to 11 am
Available vaccines will be fighter at
johnson and johnson for a
complete list of vaccination sites you can
visit our page and no snap
dotcom the section at  Spanish and now
we turn to the weather forecast today
we will have a hot day with
temperatures reaching 107 degrees
with some breezes in the valley
we expect temperatures to exceed
105 degrees for the weekend and it
registers even more heat for next
week
remember to stay hydrated  and not be
exposed to the sun for a long period of
time nice Friday the task lanzelotti greets you
with the brief informative of
iu is not now espanyol